ich habe versucht mich über neuen Videos
hinweg von nichts zu einem Porsche 944
hoch zu handeln und es hat tatsächlich
geklappt dieser Porsche 944 soll aber
kein normaler 944 bleiben wir wollen
nämlich Tausende von Kilometern in einer
Rallye mit diesem Auto durch komplett
Europa fahren und genau dieses Auto gilt
es jetzt zu kaufen und dann selber zu
bauen
[Musik]
als allererstes mussten wir ein Auto
kaufen
aber warum eigentlich 944 924 der
Vorgänger in diesem Modells ist etwas zu
alt und zu klapprig für meinen Geschmack
die ganze 911 ist so ziemlich in egal
welcher Generation deutlich teurer also
wusste ich es soll einen 944 sein aber
welcher denn uns ganz einfach zu machen
es gibt Standard Porsche 944 es gibt 944
Turbos mit einem Turbolader und 944 S2
die S2 von ungefähr bei 20.000 € an
genauso wie die Turbo die beide ein
bisschen mehr PS haben als der Standard
49 dieses Geld hatten wir aber nicht
deswegen ist die Wahl auf einen Standard
163 PS starken Porsche 944 gefallen
nicht nur ist diesen Modell bezahlbar
sondern 163 PS in so einem Auto geben
schon wirklich was her und man kann eine
Menge Spaß haben ohne dafür 30 40 50.000
€ ausgeben zu müssen und es ist halt ein
Porsche das Ding ist mein absolutes
Highlight in Trader Staffel 1 war es die
Rolex zu erarbeiten und daran an
jemanden von euch zu verschenken und
deswegen machen wir es dieses mal genau
wieder so der Porsche den ich hier Umbau
mit allen Umbauten so wie er am Ende
hier steht wird an jemanden von euch
verlost und wie das alles funktioniert
und wie ihr den gewinnen könnt erfahrt
ihr am Ende des Videos ratsam ist es auf
jeden Fall schon mal den Kanal zu
abonnieren damit ihr das und alle
weiteren Videos nicht verpasst jetzt
viel Spaß aber und damit nach all diesen
Strapazen stehe ich hier an meinem neuen
Auto einem Porsche 944 bezahlt habe ich
9 1/2000 € und das Auto ist bei weitem
nicht im Westen Zustand wir nehmen uns
so ziemlich alles vor auch die Sachen
die eigentlich noch okay sind denn das
Auto soll nicht so bleiben wie es ist es
wird zu einem Offroad Rally Porsche 944
aber wie soll die Karre in meiner Traum
Vorstellung aussehen
Spurverbreiterung um bulliger zu wirken
und höherlegungen um Offroad tauglich zu
sein Offroad Reifen und extra
pulverbeschichtete neue Felgen und und
Heckstoßstange in Eigenbau
Dachgepäckträger inklusive Rallye
Outdoor Ausrüstung Licht Licht und noch
mal Licht um genau zu sein so viel Licht
das in Deutschland nicht mal erlaubt ist
komplett neuer im Raum mit Lenkrad
sitzen und neuer Beschallung lackieren
folieren und unheimlich viele Details
und so ziemlich alles darauf ausgelegt
mit diesem Auto wirklich Abenteuer
erleben zu können bei so einem
kompletten Umbau von Hinterachse bis
nachträger mit unheimlich vielen Teilen
und Komponenten aus verschiedenen Shops
kann es schnell mal passieren dass man
den Überblick nicht mehr über die Teile
sondern auch über seine Kosten verliert
und hier kommt FinanzBuch der Partner
des heutigen Videos ins Spiel FinanzBuch
ist dein digitaler finanzassistent der
alle deine ein und Ausgaben über mehrere
Konten verteilt Track dabei ist es
völlig egal ob girokon sparkont PayPal
oder sogar Aktiendepot und das Beste das
ganze ist komplett kostenlos ihr seht
also was reinkommt viel wichtiger aber
noch ihr seht was rausgeht weißt du zum
Beispiel wie viel arbeitest du gerade
hast die App erkennt dich regelmäßige
Kontobewegungen Verträge und gibt euch
eine Möglichkeit diese mit wenigen
Klicks in der App direkt rechtssicher
kündigen zu können die App basiert auf
künstliche Intelligenz und lernt anhand
eures Einnahmen und Ausgabeverhalten
euch einen guten Überblick über eure
Finanzen und viel wichtiger eure
Sparpotenziale zu geben vielleicht zeigt
euer Konto 1000 € an die App weiß aber
das noch Handyvertrag Miete und GZ weg
müssen und euch eigentlich real nur 450
€ bleiben das zu wissen ist unheimlich
wichtig damit die nicht mehr ausgeht als
ihr habt und besser planen könnt über
den ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
und mit dem Code Dave könnt ihr
finanzguru Plus für ganze 3 Monate
komplett kostenlos testen damit bekommt
ihr noch mal eine Menge mehr
Möglichkeiten wie verschiedene Analysen
smarte Budget Vorschläge und ihr könnt
zukünftige Buchungen sehen also ladet
euch die App jetzt herunter registriert
euch verknüpft eure Konten tragt den
Code Dave ein und erlangt so volle
Übersicht über eure Finanzen ein riesen
Dankeschön an finanzberuf für die
Unterstützung dieses Projekts und dass
sie mir bzw euch dabei helfen einen
Schritt näher zum Porsche zu kommen und
jetzt viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video wie
zur Hölle baue ich aber jetzt dieses
Auto nach meinen Vorstellungen um
offensichtlich kann ich das nicht
alleine ich habe mir Unterstützung von
der so ziemlich krassesten Firma für
genau solche Themen geholt Rennen klasse
[Musik]
das Ding kommt direkt auf die Bühne wir
haben unheimlich viel Zeug bestellt und
all das werden wir im Schnelldurchlauf
in den nächsten Tagen umbauen auf die
Bühne fangen an mit dem Basics und
arbeiten uns weiter vor bis die Karre
fertig ist von uns tausende Kilometer
durch Europa geprügelt werden zu können
ja richtig gehört wir machen alles im
Schnelldurchlauf und wir haben wirklich
nur fünf Tage Zeit um alles an dem Auto
zu verändern was wir verändern wollen
und wie ihr mich kennt habe ich keinen
Tag Puffer eingebaut denn die Rally
mehrere tausend Kilometer durch Europa
die in den nächsten Videos kommt startet
einen Tag später Tag sechs bedeutet auch
ist darf nichts schief gehen und alles
muss wirklich on time funktionieren das
werden wir noch sehen denn das Auto hat
einige Mängel die dem Werkstattmeister
mag direkt aufgefallen sind Benzin hast
du schon gesagt
ist kaputt und allgemein tropft es
überall so ein bisschen einige Stellen
sind nachlackiert die Vorderachse ist
ausgeschlagen und wir haben
Radlagerspiel den Lüft der Schlauch der
Lichtmaschine hat das Zeitliche gesegnet
und er ist ab und der Zigarettenanzünder
und die Digitaluhr im Armaturenbrett
haben keinerlei Funktionen also sie
haben eigentlich Funktionen aber sie
funktionieren gerade nicht und auch wenn
sich das hier nach einer ellenlangen
Liste anhört ist das ziemlich okay es
ist halt kein Neuwagen mehr das Auto ist
38 Jahre alt hat vier Vorbesitzer und
insgesamt 170.000 km gelaufen das
Wichtige ist dass die Hauptfunktion alle
funktioniert in meinem traumszenario
läuft das Auto noch 170.000 weitere
Kilometer was laut den Rennklasse Jungs
auch gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich ist
unter der Motorhaube befindet sich
nämlich ein 2,5 Liter 4 Zylinder Audi
Motor ja ein Audi Motor in einem Porsche
aber warum ist das eigentlich so für die
Antwort dieser Frage Reisen für 50 Jahre
in der Zeit zurück ursprünglich Plan
Porsche in Zusammenarbeit mit Volkswagen
den neuen Sportwagen zu entwickeln die
Idee war das Porsche das Design und die
technische Entwicklung übernehmen würde
während Volkswagen die Produktion
übernehmen sollte das Problem die Kosten
für das Projekt sind unheimlich schnell
ins Unermessliche gestiegen und
Volkswagen zog sich aus finanziellen
Gründen zurück hat dann beschlossen die
die Entwicklung nicht aufzugeben sondern
einfach alleine weiterzumachen und
vielleicht in der Produktion um weiter
mit schmaleren Kosten rechnen zu können
auf Kooperationspartner zu vertrauen und
so ein haben sie für den Motor mit Audi
gefunden der Motor ist natürlich nur ein
Beispiel aber im Prinzip besteht das
Auto an super vielen Stellen aus
irgendwelchen Teilen von VW und Audi und
das einfach mit dem Ziel ein etwas
günstigeren Sportwagen auf die Beine zu
stellen und das haben sie geschafft und
ich profitiere 2023 immer noch davon
denn so habe ich die Möglichkeit und
auch ihr also weniger als 10.000 € einen
echten Porsche zu bekommen auch wenn
viele der neuen ever Fans sagen würden
dass es kein echter Porsche ist hier
hinter mir seht ihr schon alle Teile die
wir für den Umbau brauchen wir wirklich
eine Menge eingekauft von A bis Z ist
alles dabei in den nächsten Tagen bauen
alles um besonders darauf freue ich mich
richtig die Jungs müssen gerade
Restfederweg an der Vorder und an der
Hinterachse wir haben natürlich eine
ordentliche Höherlegung von von 48 und
hinten auf und 48 mm geplant vorne ist
es quasi kein Problem da gibt's dahinter
setze die werden damit reingesetzt und
dann wird einfach wirklich ein
Abstandshalter mit eingebaut dann
Spurverbreiterung andere Felgen und viel
fettere Reifen und auf der Hinterachse
ein bisschen umständlicher da kümmern
wir uns gleich um ich habe extra
Hackmesser Felgen gekauft die deutlich
kantiger sind weil sie mir besser
gefallen und weil sie besser zu diesem
Offroad character passen um dann die
fettesten Reifen drauf zu ziehen die ich
finden
dort
überlegen alleine durch die Aufbauhöhe
der Reifen kommen wir ja ein paar
Zentimeter hoch also wir haben jetzt
hier ungefähr 14 cm
Aufbauhöhe und wir haben ja 48 mm Spacer
Höherlegung werden wahrscheinlich wird
das Auto am Ende fünfeinhalb 6 cm höher
liegen als vorher
steht ja schon richtig so wird Porsche
Monstertruck damit das alles aber noch
stimmiger wird habe ich mich für eine 28
mm spurverarbeitung entschieden wenn
Schrauben nicht losgehen und man fängt
er an dran rum zu mursen und man
verkackt den Kopf also so dass die
Schraube rund wird dann hast du im
Normalfall ein richtiges Problem es gibt
so ein Werkzeug setzt du an bei Festen
Schrauben Haus einmal oben drauf und
dann haut er die Dritte oder eine
viertel Umdrehung los um Schrauben in so
Problemfällen lösen zu können
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also jetzt gerade setzen wir die neuen
Bolzen für die Spurplatten hinten ein
super spack passt gerade so das Loch in
die die verlängerten Stehbolzen
reinkommen wird angewärmt damit es sich
ausdehnt und die Stehbolzen selber haben
wir in die Gefriertruhe getan damit die
einfrieren bzw sich zusammenziehen damit
das überhaupt zusammen passt und wir
brauchen die längeren Stehbolzen damit
genug Material zum Schrauben noch ist
wenn wir die Spurplatte tatsächlich auch
machen
aber die dicken Reifen brauchen nicht
nur nach außen bisschen Platz sondern
auch nach oben bedeutet wir müssen die
Karre hochlegen und das nicht nur ein
bisschen sondern richtig insgesamt 48 mm
an der Vorderachse durch Spacer die
relativ einfach einzubauen waren da
kommen im Prinzip so was wie
Distanzscheiben in die Feder mit rein
wir ziehen die nach unten tun die
Distanzscheiben oben rein und damit ist
die Höhe Leon geschafft geil die
Hinterachse allerdings war noch mal ein
Spektakel für sich das musste alles
ausgebaut werden um an die Hinterachse
zu kommen auf der Achse sieht man VW und
Audi Logo der 944 hat nämlich eine
Hinterachse die ist uns erlaubt ohne
extra neue Teile kaufen zu müssen über
die Höhe oder Tieferlegung des Autos
entscheiden zu können hört sich gut an
ist aber absolut kein Standard mehr und
das bedeutet dass Anton und Max sich
diesen gesamten Prozess auch erstmal
erarbeiten muss das was jetzt hier
tricky ist es einfach wir müssen das
jetzt alles aufschrauben und abschenke
abschrauben und eben den drehst
versetzen damit wir hinten die höhere
Bodenfreiheit bekommen hier wird jetzt
alles aufgeschraubt damit höher gelegt
und dann sind wir alle happy und dann
ging es los nur mit dieser Information
hallo David Henry parat ich habe gerade
eine Hinterachse vom 944 vor mir liegen
und ich wollte fragen ob du aus dem Kopf
noch weißt wie viel Zähne ihr die
hochgeschraubt habt für die 48
Millimeter
[Musik]
okay
quasi Vorbild für unser Bild Vorbild für
unseren Umbau Jungs haben uns geholfen
wir sind schlauer geworden aber ich
glaube also zumindest mir ist gerade
erst die gesamte Dimension dieser
Hinterachse bewusst geworden viel Spaß
[Musik]
leise sein ja irgendwas passiert
so in welche Richtung müssen wir jetzt
und auch wenn sich der Prozess an der
ein oder anderen Stelle schon nicht ganz
richtig angefühlt hat haben wir weiter
durchgezogen
[Musik]
zwei
es gab nicht
[Musik]
Finale Züge Axt zusammenbauen dann kommt
wieder rein dann sind wir fertig kein
Problem
und das dachte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt
wirklich noch also Axel wieder rein
Räder drauf grün runter und
durf bei 84
also vorne ist mega mega geil
hinten ist zu hoch und ich denke ihr
wisst was das heißt
auseinanderbauen Drehstäbe anpassen
Achse wieder zusammenbauen Achse wieder
rein und versuch Nummer zwei Achse
umgebaut den kompletten Tag ausgefüllt
die Jungs mussten sich alles selber
erarbeiten mit einem kleinen Tipp
bekommen der uns etwas in die falsche
Richtung geleistet hat und das hier
könnte jetzt das Finale Setup für die
Heckachse für die Höherlegung der ganzen
zu sein
[Musik]
es hat wirklich geklappt es ist zwar der
gesamte erste Tag nur für die
Höherlegung aufgegangen aber wir waren
unheimlich happy weil ohne die
Höherlegung der gesamte Umbau wirklich
nur halb so cool gewesen wäre einfach
ein Monstertruck hier kommt noch ein
gedachgepäckträger drauf wir kommen noch
Lampen dran hier an die Seite kommt noch
dran also der wird von einem schmalen
kleinen Oldtimer zu einem richtig
breiten hohen Bullen hammergeil
hammer geil weiter geht's mit Tag Nummer
zwei für die Jungs sind schon fleißig am
abschrauben Stoßstange ab die ganz
Verkleidungsteile ab denn die Karre wird
verliert der Verlierer kommt gleich
schaut sich das an und guckt ob er das
äh in kürzester Zeit hier für uns
umsetzen kann die liegen die ganzen
Teile die schon abgebaut sind die werden
nicht nur verliert sondern wir tauschen
auch ein Teil aus deswegen haben wir uns
von 944 Turbo ein front-teil bestellt
das ist dieses hier bei meinem Auto was
grundsätzliche vorne geschlossen wenn
jetzt hier diese vier Öffnungen und in
mit dieser Öffnung kommt eine Lampe und
dann haben wir nicht nur Licht auf dem
Dachgepäckträger sondern auch vorne in
der Front also richtig hell abseits von
den ganzen Basteleien mussten wir auch
schon alles für den Folierer vorbereiten
das bedeutet alles raus und ab was
entweder nicht mitpoliert werden soll
oder was beim Polieren stört geplant war
eigentlich nur der Umbau der
Frontstoßstange Markus der über Papst 33
aber Teile für so ziemlich alle Autos
verkauft hatte einen anderen einfallen
ist eigentlich schon
46 das passt ja ziemlich perfekt
Teil dieses Einfalls war ein barschbach
eines BMW E46 ja das sind zwei
verschiedene Autos aber so lief das
grundsätzlich war die forms schon ganz
okay aber wir mussten noch einiges
anpassen
[Musik]
7 cm brauchen wir eine Verbindungsstück
hinten dran zu machen und das ist jetzt
gerade das Problem und dafür suchen wir
jetzt eine Lösung
[Musik]
und hier will ich auch noch mal ein
großes Dankeschön an Rennklasse
aussprechen Anton Marc Marcus und alle
anderen die in irgendeiner Weise dabei
geholfen haben jeden Tag neue Ideen mit
einfließen zu lassen wie zum Beispiel
den Dashboard der einfach komplett
kurzfristig an Tag 2 umgebaut angepasst
und eingebaut wurde das war unglaublich
und wirklich eine Professionalität wie
ich sie selten erlebt habe also vielen
Dank ein klasse wenn ihr irgendwas
braucht Check-In Klasse ab die können
wirklich so ziemlich alles möglich
machen was ihr im Autobereich haben
richtig krank Freestyle Idee von Markus
vorher wäre der Plan gewesen dass wir
gar nichts machen also vorne kommen
Lampen und von vorne sieht der cool aus
aber von hinten wäre er so geblieben wie
er ist nur ein bisschen höher stand
jetzt haben wir hinten auch eine
Monstertruck also genauso wie
geil was in zwei Tagen an progress
möglich war ist wirklich unglaublich und
ich weiß ihr wartet alle darauf jetzt
kommen wir dazu wie ihr das Auto
gewinnen könnt ab heute ist jeder Euro
den ihr auf der Thermik Website umsetzt
und das völlig egal ob für eine alte
oder für die neue Kollektion ein entry
im Lostopf das bedeutet ihr könnt mich
über Timex supporten bekommt dafür ein
T-Shirt zurück und auch die Möglichkeit
den Porsche 944 zu gewinnen das Ding ist
ihr habt aber natürlich auch die
Möglichkeit an dem Gewinnspiel
mitzumachen ohne etwas ausgegeben zu
müssen und das auf der tarmac Instagram
Seite ihr müsst damit folgen den
postleiten drei Leute markieren und seid
damit dann automatisch mit fünf entrys
im Lostopf also so wie als hättet ihr
fünf Euro im Thermomix Shop ausgegeben
so hat jeder von euch die Möglichkeit
mitzumachen die Leute die Lust haben was
bei mir zu kaufen und auf die die keine
Lust haben die Aktion läuft ab heute den
9 juli bis zum 30 Juli und das Beste am
29 juli haben wir in köln-up store in
dem wir nicht nur das Auto sondern auch
eine Menge Fotos die wir über die
letzten Jahre hier mit der gesamten
tarmac Crew gemacht haben ausstellen und
dort auch Sachen verkaufen wir haben
kostenlose Getränke gute Mucke das Auto
dort ausgestellt so dass ihr euch das
auch mal anschauen könnt und machen uns
dort eine gute Zeit also kommt am 29
vorbei und nehmt gerne bis zum 30 an der
Aktion teil alle Links zum Timex Shop
zum Mitmachen beim Gewinnspiel und so
weiter sind in der Videobeschreibung das
war's mit umbauvideo Nummer eins ich
freue mich riesig auf Folge 2 und vor
allem was ihr zu dem Auto sagt denn es
ist wirklich geisteskrank geworden
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
das Video zu liken und dann sehen wir
uns nächste Woche wieder macht es gut
ciao